the world
will remember this day
Trinity test and the revelation of the
first atomic explosion to the world was
one of the most important moments in the
20th century it was a massive miraculous
project that many thousands of people
were involved with it touched government
it touched science it had huge
ramifications for all sorts of Ordinary
People the Trinity test and the
development and the race and the fact
that it was all attempting to save kind
of humanity from fascism World War II
would be over our boys would come home
this is a matter of life and death but I
can perform this miracle what was really
interesting was going back and trying to
understand what these guys were thinking
and the terrible decisions that were
placed in front of them I
don't if we can be interested for such a
weapon but I but I'm not too scared we
live in the world that we live in
because of what happened at Los Alamos
why would we go to the middle of nowhere
for who knows how long how about because
this is the most important thing to ever
happen in the history of the world
all through Humanity we've been blinded
by ambition and pursuit and then the
ramifications are something else that's
happening isn't it I think that's why
it's so bizarre and amazing that Chris
is making this movie now we're seeing
parallels it's a profoundly overwhelming
experience watching it it's not a
history lesson it's not telling people
this is what you must learn from this
but I think it's very clear you can
reflect back on what's happening in the
world today when I asked Chris what was
interesting about why he wanted to make
it he said I always found that very
interesting that when they were doing
the Trinity test they were asked what
are the chances of this going wrong and
then it blowing up the entire world
chances are near zero
near zero what do you want for theory of
loan zero would be nice didn't need a
shorts what is that decision to just
still go ahead and do it it's an
extraordinary moment in human history
and I wanted to take the audience into
that room and be there when that button
is pushed and really fully bring the
audience to This Moment In Time
why
[Music]